[Musik]
hey leute seid doch mal ganz ehrlich
wenn ihr an der bäckerei vorbei läuft
gerade jetzt zu dieser jahreszeit was
schlicht euch am allermeisten ins
aufrechten ich habe es ehrlich
bei mir sind die zwetschgenkuchen auf
diesem bild und dann so richtig schön
serviert an dieser glasfront und ich
habe mir überlegt wir machen jetzt einen
zwetschgenkuchen vom blech genauso wie
vom bäcker und dafür zeige ich euch
jetzt die zutaten wir machen ein
hefeteig aus mehl milch außerdem butter
hefe hier nämlich heute trockenhefe
zucker etwas salz und natürlich frischen
zwetschgen ich mache den hefeteig heute
mit den händen und ich benutze ein
anderes mehr ich nutze sonst mal gerne
das mehl typ 405 das ist so das
geläufigste das klassische heute nämlich
aber weit 550 denn ihr werdet staunen
das ist besonders gut für weiße wäsche
geeignet also für schwarz-rot zum
beispiel ist nicht so gut geeignet aber
umso besser eben auch für weiße gebäcke
wie hier führt zum beispiel und ich habe
jetzt meine hilfe hier schon in meiner
schüssel gegeben und heute aber dich
auch mit trockenhefe und da gebe ich
jetzt die halbe packung rein
ich mache übrigens ein halbes blech ihr
leben ich bin ja mit dem haben sie
alleine unsere familien sind im urlaub
ich habe zwar eine ganz liebe nachbarin
die auch was von mir abbekommen aber ein
halbes blech reicht mir wenn ihr ein
ganzes bild machen wollt dann verdoppelt
einfach die mengenangaben und jetzt gibt
die hier noch zucker mit dazu die prise
salz und dann die flüssigen zutaten
jetzt habe ich den teig drei minuten auf
der arbeitsfläche geknetet und ihr
bekommt dann so ein gefühl dafür wann
der fertig ist also drei bis vier
minuten reicht hier schon total und ihr
könnt auch immer mal wieder ein bisschen
mehl dazugeben wenn ihr märkte braucht
noch ein bisschen was und jetzt lassen
wir unseren hefeteig gehen wenn das
jetzt noch mal ganz kurz zu einer kugel
rollen das mag ich dann immer am
liebsten und mit mir wieder meine
schüsse die von grad eben gibt am nil
rhein einmal unten
hier führt rein einmal oben ein bisschen
mehl und jetzt mit einem tuch abdecken
und 30 minuten lang gehen lassen
ein hefeteig ist gleich soweit und ich
bereite jetzt hier schon mal die
zwetschge hinzu das heißt ich habe sie
einmal
neben den kern raus und dann nämlich
jeder hälfte und teile sie nochmal durch
drei also ich finde so resch ok also für
mich ist das so optimal es kommt
natürlich auch auf die größe der
zwetschgen an
und dann machen wir gleich auch schon
weiter ich den ofen auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 190 grad ober und
unterhitze und gleich bereiten wir
unseren backen zu und zwar habe ich
jetzt meinen backblech mit backpapier
ausgelegte das ist ganz wichtig damit
wir den kuchen später lösen können und
ein paar gramm drum herum gelegt ist
nämlich mein hier verteilt und gibt den
hier einmal unten rein und breite den
mit den händen aus bei trockenhefe habt
ihr ja den vorteil dass es eigentlich
nicht gehen muss aber dadurch dass wir
das jetzt eine halbe stunde haben
entspannen lassen ist es ein bisschen
geschmeidiger man kann es ein bisschen
besser verarbeiten und ich musste kein
nudelholz sondern einfach nur die finger
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch den bug ram mit
backpapier eingeschlagen damit ihr
einfach mehr stabilität habt aber es
entfällt alles wenn ihren ganz normalen
blechkuchen macht das heißt einfach die
doppelte menge nimmt das könnte er dann
selbst entscheiden und jetzt gebe ich
hier ganz einfach die zwetschgen
obendrauf und zwar mit der innenseite
nach oben und das wäre es eigentlich
auch schon gewesen mehr nicht so einfach
geht's
und jetzt packen wir die swisscom
blechkuchen für 30 bis 35 minuten
[Musik]
ich finde es gibt nichts über ein stück
lauwarm zwetschgenkuchen mit frisch auf
geschlagener sahne wenn ihr stand nach
backen möchte einmal unten in die
infobox schorn da schreibe ich euch wie
immer alle ganz genaue mengenangaben und
dann schön screenshot machen einkaufen
gehen und nach backen und vergesst nicht
eure fotos mit dem hashtag s kitchen zu
decken dann kann ich sie mir auch
ansehen auf instagram und auf facebook
ansonsten einen deutschen nach oben da
lassen aber nicht vergessen und am
besten auch die glocke aktivieren damit
ihr auch nichts mehr verpasst und jetzt
ganz ganz ganz viel freude beim
nachbacken und bis zum nächsten rezept
von mir
[Musik]